[Music]
and we had a day out
there to adjust and rest and do things
prince philip went i went to sleep
in a little room that was off to one
side
the queen was at a desk writing letter's
phone rang my colleague said
mike is a ghastly river going around
that the king has died
and they used it amongst all the press
people there and then they were saying
that they'd heard
so i said well martin that's frightening
but
i cannot do a thing on a rumor like that
i mean i just won't do anything and he
said no i'm not suggesting he should
darn went the phone i saw a radio
on the shelf above me and there's a
door open to where the queen is sitting
so i shut the door
and switched on the radio and hunted
about
the bbc and then i could hear the bell
of um big ben
what's up we need cars so my hair stood
up a little bit more
this is london it tears with the
greatest sorrow that we make the
following announcement
at 10 45 today february the 6th
1952 that the king
passed peacefully away in his sleep
earlier this morning
and uh that was that so there was
drought into where prince philip was
sleeping and told him
his first reaction was one of
almost as a huge way to get him
and he just stood there
silently in thought the implications of
the fact that she's becoming the queen
[Music]
and then he straightened himself up and
he went into delhi queen
and she was in you know weeping
desperately for the loss of her father
they walked up and down together very
close
and then she straightened up
[Music]
fully uh conscious of the fact that she
was queen
and that she must tend to that affair
immediately